you both worked in Hollywood for a very
long time and I'm curious if someone has
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why
oh you're looking at me
um
you know I think I would just like them
to smile that's all when you look at me
I want you to smile that that's
you know because I haven't done any you
know I haven't done RoboCop because I
would imagine you don't want that to
happen then but for me I would like them
to go oh I know her and smile that's
what I like
um well Deborah Joe mentioned RoboCop
which of course has did an awful lot for
me and was terrific fun to do it
um but I would say I would like them to
see a patriot on Amazon which I did a
couple was that the question
wasn't that the question what would you
like people to see if they're not
familiar with your background yeah uh I
did not know that I
misinterpreted the question
Oh but you did a good job though
I thought your answer was good oh okay
so uh I've seen all all 10 episodes of
that 90s show I'm sure it's gonna be a
hit oh thank you but the series wouldn't
work without the two of you you're
you're instrumental in in connecting the
two series and I'm curious what was it
like behind the scenes when they first
approached you to do this you know
because it you guys are really important
for the success of this show and I'm
curious how much were they figuring out
what happens if you guys don't want to
do it you know how is this show going to
get made
I don't think they would have made it
uh not certainly not in this uh format I
mean I guess they could have uh done um
well no they couldn't because Dover had
another show but you know I I I was told
they wouldn't have done it well they
certainly wouldn't have done it this way
I am so curious what was it like because
uh making this series whole new cast all
um what was it like making this one
versus the original You Know That 70s
Show because also that one was I believe
20 something episodes a season and this
was you know 10. well for me the
difference I already knew the character
so in 70s Show I was figuring out the K
we were all kind of figuring out our
characters but going into this already
knew Kitty I I knew who Kitty was so I
felt like I had a leg up you know and
and with less episodes that was very
valuable because I didn't have to do
this you know ways four episodes doing
investigating as to who she was it was
there from the beginning that's my
answer what's yours it's a good answer
that's a really good answer what was the
question again who knows okay
um
yeah I think that uh yes before we were
doing uh 25 episodes this season we're
only doing 10 this time
um
but that you know that that was good
especially I think at the beginning you
know uh if we were trying to do 25
episodes I think it would have kind of
run us all into the ground but um
I
I think the fact that the writers
um in particular the creators of the
show uh Bonnie and Terry uh Turner and
uh and Greg metler but all three of whom
had worked on the previous show
um
they they knew where to go there they
also had a leg up as opposed to having
to develop all these things as it went
along if you go back and look at the
beginning of the 70s Show to see how
much we changed how much the show
changed uh in uh in the time that it was
on the air here
they already knew what was going to work
you know they already knew that uh
dumbass is going to work you know and
they knew that that Deborah Joe was
going to be able to laugh and you know
they had all these things going right
from the beginning uh speaking of
dumbass how often in real life do people
want you to to call them a dumbass
amazingly a lot you know when I it's
just it's it's amazing to me
um that they they you know you guys
I don't maybe one woman asked me to call
her a dumbass but pretty much it's guys
and they come up and they go hey man can
you call me a dumbass and what I used to
say was anybody who wants to be called a
dumbass is a dumbass and then I'd call
him a dumbass and they'd be happy so
yeah but I don't know why I have no idea
what that comes from I think I think
they feel that it kind of pulls them and
give makes them a little tiny bit a part
of the show I agree um I believe this is
the first time for both of you that
you've been given an executive producer
credit it
um on a show I could be wrong what does
it mean for both of you to actually get
credited as a producer well
you want to thank this go ahead
um
I think that this first season it it
really we really didn't uh we didn't
really have time to make use of that
that uh you know we're all everybody is
so busy developing the show that I think
that for us to start saying hey you know
we think that uh you know would have
just kind of made everything very
difficult so we were also dealing uh you
know a big difference from 70's Show was
dealing with covid in the 90s show and
there were a lot of
you there was just a lot of pulling
together with that and a lot of figuring
out with that so that that took a lot of
time you know it was there was a lot of
navigating you know with 90s show
um and I think we all just everybody
just kind of pitched in and did what
they could do so I'm not really exactly
sure about the executive producer yet
but we will be finding out hopefully
it's a good thing to add to the IMDb
profile
um I have to rap I'm just gonna say
congrats I really do hope the show is a
big hit thank you Steve thank you thank
you great fun talking to you thanks